How do we solve a system of linear equations
using matrices and determinants?
How do we solve for the values of X and Y here?
So one way is by solving them using one of the
regular techniques we have seen.
Or we can use matrices to solve them.
Yes matrices!
To solve the equations using matrices and determinants
we first need to write them in the matrix form.
So we first write the matrix of the coefficients.
For the first equation, the coefficients are two and minus one.
And for the second, the coefficients are three and two.
This is the matrix of coefficients of the two variables.
And this will be multiplied with the matrix
which has the column of variables.
The variables are X and Y.
So a matrix with the coefficients,
multiplied with a matrix with a column of variables.
And this product is equal to a matrix
with a column of the constants on the right hand side.
That will be 4 and 13.
This is the matrix form of the above system of equations.
Why do we say that this is the matrix form?
We will know why when we multiply these two matrices.
Do you remember multiplication of matrices?
To know if two matrices can be multiplied,
we need to check their order.
The order of this matrix is two by two,
and that of this one is two by one.
Two rows two columns and two rows one column.
As the second and the third numbers are the same,
these matrices are compatible for multiplication.
The order of the resulting matrix
will be the first number by the fourth number.
It will be two by one.
So we multiply the first row of this matrix
with the first column of this matrix and write the product here.
And then multiply the second row of this matrix
What will be the product of these two?
It will be '2x minus y'.
And the product of these two will be '3x plus 2y'.
This is the product of these two matrices.
And this matrix will be written as is.
Now you see why this is the matrix form of the system of equations.
As these two matrices are equal,
we can say that '2x minus y' will equal 4.
And '3x plus 2y' will equal 13.
Same as these two equations!
But let's come back to the important point.
How does writing it in matrix form help us solve the equations?
Let's see that on the right hand side.
This can be written as 'A times X' is equal to B.
We have called this one matrix A.
and this matrix X and this matrix B.
'A times X' is equal to B.
What we're interested in is matrix X.
That will give us the values of variables X and Y.
So to get X on the left hand side,
we multiply both sides with A inverse.
We get the left hand side as 'A inverse times AX'.
And the right hand side as 'A inverse times B'.
Now 'A inverse times A' will equal the identity matrix.
We get this!
And we know that the 'identity matrix times any matrix'
will give us that same matrix.
So the left hand side will equal matrix X.
And the right hand side will be 'A inverse times matrix B'.
That's how we get matrix X.
We multiply 'A inverse with B'.
So when we are given the two equations,
we write it in this form, find the inverse of this matrix,
and multiply it with this to get matrix X.
And that will give us the values of the variables.
We will solve this example in the next lesson.